you remember me at all Stephen Crowder
at all no not familiar this is you
threatening to slash my tires here
remember this slashing my tires and
actually funny enough also also the
Robert E Lee statue seems you helped to
face we're trying to work let me ask you
why do you think it's okay to threaten
to slash someone's tires you need to get
out or we're going to call the police do
it you know what Les let's call the
police officers because a matter of fact
we actually have that no no actually I
would like to speak with the police
we're about to file a report very soon
okay you should do that man this is a
part of being a man is owning up to the
actions here when you threaten violence
against someone sir when you threaten
violence against someone
is taking ownership of your actions
taking responsibility could you just say
hey you're sorry take this down could
you take this down could you take it
down because there are other people it's
not going anywhere oh there you go he
just admitted to doing it